- [Mark] All right, Vicky.
Vicky, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Vicky] I grew up in Hildale, Utah.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both parents growing up as a kid?
- My...
I don't know if you've
heard of the Warren Jeffs.
- [Mark] Warren Jeffs,
the Mormon polygamist?
- Polygamy.
I grew up, I was born and
raised in the polygamy.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Mm-hm. (light chuckle)
- [Mark] So one of the
extremist Mormon sects
down in southern Utah.
- My dad has two wives,
and I was homeschooled first,
second, and third grade.
Actually, first and second grade.
And, oh, first, second I'm homeschooled.
Third grade, private school.
Fourth grade, homeschooled.
Then fifth and sixth,
also homeschool.
Then seventh and eighth
went to private school.
- [Mark] And how many brothers
and sisters do you have?
- My mom has 14 kids. I'm number seven.
And then my dad's other wife has nine.
So like 25 siblings I think.
- [Mark] So, today you're
working as a prostitute.
- Well, I been doin'
prostitution or whatever,
body work, for three years now.
I started out as body work
(indistinct) anything.
I was doin' good until I
came out here from Utah.
And since I been out here,
it's been harder for me.
And I actually quit doing
the prostitution for a while,
for a good year just 'cause it was...
I wasn't liking it.
But now my boyfriend,
well ex now, broke up with me.
- [Mark] You're back to it.
And drugs are a part of your life now?
- Yeah, they kind of...
- [Mark] What's your drug today?
- Today I prefer
the cocaine,
but it's too expensive,
so usually now only
doin' crystal and heroin.
- [Mark] How old were you when
you left your Mormon family
back in Utah?
- How old was I when I left home?
- [Mark] Yes.
- When I left home, I was 19.
- [Mark] 19.
- Yeah, I'd just turned 19 in September.
- [Mark] And did you leave
because you were uncomfortable
with that lifestyle, or...?
- I was 10 years old
when I knew it was wrong.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- I was 10 years old when (indistinct).
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
I'm having a hard time understanding you.
- I was 10 years old
when I knew it was wrong.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Yeah.
My dad married a lady who
was five years older than me.
She was 15, and I was 10.
- [Mark] And your dad was how old?
- Like, 40 I think.
30, 40.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah. And I lost my
respect for 'em right there.
- [Mark] So that was the
point when you knew something.
- That's when I knew it wasn't right.
Just 'cause he was...
I don't... I feel like he treated my mom
like she was nothing after that.
- [Mark] What is your opinion
of that whole religion,
and that community?
I've photographed up there before as well,
and maybe a different
community than yours,
but I've seen them as an
honest, hard-working bunch
that just happen to have
multiple wives and lots of kids.
But, you know it much better than I do.
What was your impression of it?
- Well, they are hard working.
I mean, basically growing up,
me personally, and everybody in my family
the girls would all learn how to sew
by time they're eight years old.
By time we hit eight,
we pretty much an adult kinda thing.
And I lived on a farm,
so I was taking care of
all the farm animals.
Milking the cow,
feedin', gathering the eggs,
feeding the chickens, and
milking the cow as well.
Making our own yogurt and cheese.
And I learned how to
bake when I was eight,
learned how to sew when I was eight.
Also knew how to braid
hair and change diapers
by time I was eight years old, as well.
Yeah.
- [Mark] So, but again, the question was
what's your impression of that
community and the religion?
- I don't know. I don't think it's right.
I feel like it's...
Too much...
Uh...
Too much brain washing,
too much lies, too much...
- [Mark] Do you the women are...
- Huh?
- [Mark] Do you feel like the
women are tricked or forced,
or brainwashed into marrying
at a very early age,
and accepting multiple...
- So, all the girls that are there
are the ones that have
born into it already.
So, of course, they're
already brainwashed,
and of course they can
think that that's right
because they're born into that.
Because that's just like...
- [Mark] But, so were
you, and yet you saw...
- Yeah, me too.
a way out.
- (indistinct) and think for ourselves
because not very many of 'em
could think for themselves out there
'cause they'll try to and then
they'll be told it was wrong
because, you know.
So there's very few of them
that actually have the strength to see it.
Not only see it, but
also take a step forward,
and make a move.
- [Mark] So, where are you living today?
- [Vicky] Today I'm kinda
still living on the street.
- [Mark] Down here on Skid Row?
- [Vicky] Yeah.
- [Mark] Are you in a tent, or...?
- [Vicky] Well, I kinda stay in the car,
and at night, I used to try to get a hotel
if I could get the money for a room,
and I'd stay in a room at night.
But usually during the
day, I'm in the car, or...
I'm walkin' around tryna to....
- [Mark] Do you see any connection
between the life you lived in Utah,
in a
polygamist environment,
and what you're doing today?
- [Vicky] I don't see any
connection whatsoever, no.
Not really.
Because then
where do I come from?
Like, where there's more
than one wife (indistinct)...
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- [Vicky] I said there's
no connection whatsoever
that I can see there because...
- [Mark] But, I'm not
saying they do drugs,
or anything like that.
What I'm saying is that
childhood that you had
somehow may have played a part
in the fact that you're addicted to drugs
and living on the street, and
working as a prostitute, no?
- That's what I'm sayin'.
The working as a prostitute
part, no, not at all.
That just kinda came uh...
Honestly, I never saw myself doin' this
until back before my
boyfriend broke up with me.
He got arrested,
and so I kinda had to
start doin' a little work
because I couldn't keep up on the bills.
So I started doing it in Utah.
He supported me, though,
when he found out,
but he wasn't too happy at first.
- [Mark] And, how do you find...
Like, the customers you pick up now are,
they treat you well,
or do you have bad experiences sometimes?
- I have bad experiences
here and there, I mean...
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff has happened to you?
- No.
I haven't really, like,
get too far 'cause I...
Well, the worst that happened here so far
that happened to me is I got stranded.
Can't remember where it was at,
but it was about an hour
and a half from here.
Took me there,
just kinda didn't pay that well,
but took care of me nice,
then he dropped me off by
a bus stop and drove off.
He told me (indistinct) he'd
take me down all the way back,
but he didn't, so...
That's that.
- [Mark] And are you working on your own,
or with a pimp?
- I work on my own.
- [Mark] By yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You ever get arrested
or anything like that?
- I did once three years ago.
And I could've avoided it,
but I didn't 'cause the
reason why I got arrested
is that I didn't listen
to my ex at the time.
He laid down a set of
rules, and laws, whatever.
Kinda rules of what to do and not to do,
what to say, what not to say.
And I was...
I was just not gonna listen to
anything he had to say to me
'cause I was upset for some reason.
And so I went out of my way
to make sure I did nothing he
told me to do because of that.
Like they say, karma's a bitch.
That day (indistinct) take it,
and I took it anyways
and ended up in jail.
Yeah, kinda.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
Do you have children?
And where are they?
- I have one son.
- [Mark] Who's raising your son?
(sniffs)
- Sorry.
(sniffing)
- [Mark] Did you lose your son
to the system?
- No. He's still alive, I think.
It'll be his...
His dad has 'em.
- [Mark] He's with his dad?
- I think.
(sniffles and sobs)
Sorry.
- [Mark] It's okay.
- I haven't heard from 'em in five years.
- [Mark] How old is he now?
- He just turned seven June 23rd.
He's seven years old.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Do you ever have contacts with your family
back in Utah?
- I have contact with one
sister and one brother
only because the two of them
have left the religion themselves.
And that's the only way
I have contact with 'em
because they're not a part of it anymore.
My sister, Gwennie,
she's the other mom's oldest daughter.
And she's about to have her baby.
And she left the religion as well.
- [Mark] Looking back at your life,
what do you wish had been different?
You had a lot going on
with the family you had in Utah,
and then since you got into California.
- What do I wish had gone different?
- [Mark] Yeah, what do you wish
was different about your childhood,
or about your upbringing?
- A lot. (chuckles)
I wish
that I would've met my
ex before I ever even...
There's a lotta things
I wish were different.
My ex and I were together for 10 years.
But we met before I got
pregnant with my son.
But then what happened was
we weren't really together,
and I was still with my
baby's daddy at that time.
And I had the opportunity
to be with my ex,
well, my baby daddy and
my ex, his name was Ace.
But, for some reason,
I wish I wouldn't have gone
back with my baby's daddy,
but I did, and then I
got pregnant with my son.
I mean, don't get me wrong,
I love my son to death,
it's just I wish I could be in his life.
Pretty much I'm tryin' to say
is I wish I woulda had my son with
the guy who recently broke up with me.
Then at least then I'd have
him in my life here I believe.
(Vicky sighs)
- [Mark] What was the
worst time in your life?
- Worst time in my life?
I don't know.
Honestly, as years go by,
it feels like each year's
getting worse and worse
without my kid here.
- [Mark] What was the
best time in your life?
- I would have to say
about six years ago for
a good three years there.
Well you see, I met my ex in 2011.
Not my baby's daddy, but my ex.
His name is Ace. He's a black dude.
I met him in 2011,
and he just recently broke
up with me about a month ago.
I can say that my happiest that I've been
that I can remember
is the first couple years
when we were together.
He definitely had been the best thing
for me in my life as well.
He...
I get healthy when I'm around him.
And I start to gain weight.
I feel happier, and everybody around me
says I look happier, but...
The reason why we're not together anymore
is he broke up with me 'cause I kind of...
I pushed him to.
- [Mark] You what?
- I pushed him to do. I kept egging it on.
Kept doing things
that I knew would upset 'em.
And I don't know why,
but still to this day,
he would come right back and
get me if I tell 'em to, but
I don't.
The reason I don't is 'cause
I feel I don't deserve 'em.
- [Mark] Was there love in
the childhood that you had
back in Utah?
In your family?
- (indistinct)
- [Mark] Do you feel like
you were loved as a child?
- Not really. I just feel like...
Growing up,
even up until I left home,
not once did I ever hear
from my siblings or mom or dad
that I was beautiful, pretty,
or anything like that.
No one at home says, you
know, good looking, beautiful.
I didn't hear... the very first person...
The first time I heard anyone
tell me I was beautiful was...
was in March of 2011
when I met Ace, my ex.
He was the first one to tell me.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you think you've learned in life?
- Open your eyes to the
blessings that you have.
Don't take 'em for granted
because you'll look (indistinct)
when you open your eyes 'cause it's gone.
(sniffing)
To not give up.
That's why I am where
I am today, I believe
'cause I stopped caring,
and gave up on myself.
(sniffs)
After I lost my son, I feel
like there's nothing (sniffs)
to live for anymore.
(outside chatter and city noises)
(Vicky sniffing and sobbing)
Sorry.
- [Mark] Alright, Vicky.
Thank you for talking with me.
- [Vicky] No problem.
Sorry. (light chuckle)
- [Mark] It's okay. You're
going through a lot.
- [Vicky] Hmm?
- [Mark] You've been through a lot,
and you're going through a lot.